a class of high school students went on
a trip but a deadly Intruder took them
to a mysterious island now they must
kill their own friends to survive at the
dawn of the Millennium the nation
collapsed at 15% unemployment 10 million
people were out of work 800,000 students
boycotted school and juvenile crime
rights soared adults had lost all
confidence and now fearing the youth
they eventually passed the Millennium
educational reform act aka the BR act
however most of the students are still
unaware of what's going on behind them
one such student is shuya nanahara he
was in fourth grade when his mother left
and on his first day of seventh grade
his dad committed suicide he didn't have
a clue what to do and no one helped him
Japanese Society has changed drastically
and youth has stopped respecting adults
even at Shia's School the students don't
bother to obey the teachers on the first
day of the new session most of Shia's
classmates took the day off without any
apparent reason their home room teacher
katano gets heartbroken and leaves the
classroom in the hallway he gets
attacked by a student who was holding a
sharp knife the student didn't even
bother to check if katano is fine katano
doesn't say a word and resigns from his
job the students are used to such
incidents and keep living their lives as
they want they usually don't attend
school but when the school trip is
arranged the whole class decides to
enjoy this moment shuya also joined the
trip along with his best friend and
roommate noou as they are riding the bus
a cute girl named noro brings some
homemade cookies for shouya and also
asks her friend to take a picture she
seemed to have a strong crush on shuya
but shuyu seems a little distant the
night sets in and shuya opens his eyes
after falling asleep mysteriously he's
still in the bus and all the students
around him are unconscious while the bus
is driven by masked agents as they
notice shouya is awake they hit his head
to put him back to sleep shouya opens
his eyes again in a dark classroom of an
abandoned school all of his classmates
are there along with two other
mysterious boys they all are wearing
strange metal necklaces
suddenly several military Jeeps reach
the school and turn on the classroom
lights a man walks to the board to
explain the situation and this man is no
other than katano he says he is going to
take back his class and he introduces
the two mysterious boys as the transfer
students named kada and kiriyama he
tells all of them to sit down and listen
to what the BR Act is suddenly Kitano
notices nou and recognizes him as the
one who attacked him with a knife he
stopped coming to school but joined the
trip for the sake of his friends Kitano
says that because of disobedient
students like noou Japan is destroyed so
the government has passed a law called
Battle Royale aka the BR act according
to this law the students have to kill
each other until only one of them is
left the students assume that this is
just a prank so katano brings the dead
body of one of their teachers who tried
to oppose this law the students get
scared and back off katano plays a video
to explain more about this law a student
starts whispering and Kitano kills him
immediately now the the other students
can't dare to speak a word they quietly
listen to the video which tells them
that they all are present on an
uninhabited Island which is divided into
several zones Katana will make
announcements four times a day to tell
the students about the danger zone the
necklace they are wearing can help
Kitano locate them anyone who doesn't
leave the danger zone immediately his
necklace will explode if someone tries
to take it off it will explode in that
case too nou gets enraged and starts
abusing katano the teacher gets
triggered and send a signal to nobu's
necklace which explodes and kills him
the students have only 3 days and if
more than one student survives after 3
days all of them will be killed no one
will win Kitano says this all is
happening because the youth don't
respect the adults the game starts now
each student will be given a survival
bag with food map flashlight and a
random weapon each student is call it
out one by one and they leave with a bag
when shuyu is called he tells norico
that he will wait for her outside but as
soon as they step outside some of the
students start attacking already and two
of them die shuyu runs away with norico
and hides in the forest he treats her
wound and then they check their bags as
their weapons noro gets binoculars and
shuyu gets a potl both of them are
useless so there are very small chances
of their survival shuu asks about noro's
friends but she reveals that all of them
are toxic and she can't trust anyone
except shuu this reminds shuyu of his
beloved friend noou he once told shuyu
that he has a crush on noro and he
joined the trip just because noro asked
him to shuyu couldn't save him but he
will try his best to protect the girl
nou loved meanwhile the transfer student
kiriyama gets caught by a group of
bullies who want to steal his weapon but
it's just a paper fan they make fun of
him and point a machine gun towards his
head giriama is more skilled than he
looks he snatches the gun and kills all
of them not all the students have the
courage to play this deadly game and two
of them chooses to commit suicide while
some students preferred to find a hiding
spot a girl named megumi hides in an old
storage but a female bully named mitsuko
finds her she asks mumi about her weapon
and it turns out to be a stun gun to get
the stun gun mitsuko mercilessly kills
mumi the next morning the first
announcement is made which includes the
names of all the students who have died
hearing the announcement shuyu and noro
take out their maps to Mark the danger
zones they start moving away from the
danger zones but get attacked by a guy
armed with an axe while trying to defend
himself shuu accidentally kills the
attacker then they meet the other
transfer student kaada who doesn't
attack them after knowing that they
don't have any useful weapons suddenly
they hear a scream two female students
use a megaphone to ask all students to
unite and find a solution together they
are way too innocent and attract kirama
who kills them on the spot shuyu can't
believe his friends are dying like that
but kaada advises him to stop being
emotional either they can commit suicide
or not trust anyone and keep running
after the second announcement mitsuko is
caught by another student named hirono
who seems really angry because mitsuko
had stolen her boyfriend she snatches
away the sickle but mitsuko still has
the stun gun and uses it to snatch away
Hero's pistol to kill her mitsuko and
kiriyama have become the most dangerous
players and the weakest are noro and
shuyu noro Falls unconscious due to high
fever so shuyu directs her to the clinic
he noticed on the map it's the place
where kada is hiding but he lets them in
and also treats noro not everyone is
playing the game a boy named mimura has
gathered his friends so they can hack
into a computer system and call for help
he suddenly notices a microphone on the
necklace and types on the computer to
tell his friends that Kitano is
listening to their conversation now they
will communicate by writing down mimura
sends his friends to find some necessary
materials while he works on hacking a
student named Nida takes this game as a
chance to flirt with his crushed chigusa
but chigusa likes another boy named
sugimura and warns Nita to stay away but
Nita keeps teasing her by showing off
his bow and arrow suddenly the arrow
shoots out by accident and hits chig
USA's face she gets mad and uses a knife
to stab Nita several times mitsuko has
witnessed this incident and jumps in to
kill chigusa chigusa tries to run away
but the bullet has already injured her
severally while she is taking her last
breath she finally meets sugimura and
dies in his arms one day has passed and
20 students are still alive so Kitano
adds more danger zones every hour shuyu
and noro are still with kada who even
Cooks food for them he is finally
willing to share his story and shows the
picture of her girlfriend they both were
chosen for this game 3 years ago kada
even killed his best friend to save her
as there could only be one winner both
of their necklaces started beeping kaada
thought they would die together but his
girlfriend suddenly shot him kada
survived and shot back she dies in his
arms while smiling and says thank you
kada still wonders why she said that
though he won he was still forced to
play again to make the game more
interesting suddenly they hear gunfire
and hide it's kiriyama the one who
willingly joined this game just to get a
chance to kill others freely kada tells
his mates to meet him at The Shrine he
knows a way to get out of this island
kirama notices the clinic and starts
shooting at it blindly shuyu asks kada
to take care of noro and he jumps out to
distract kirama sugamura sees his friend
in danger and rushes to help help shuyu
gets shot and falls in water and
sugimura jumps after him meanwhile
mimura gets all the material he was
looking for he carries around a bomb
trigger as a memory of his uncle who
worked as a fighter mimura is planning
to shut down the game system and blast
the school with self-made bombs then all
the survivors can escape next morning
shuyu opens his eyes in the lighthouse
where a group of girls have taken
shelter sugamura brought him here and
left to find someone else the girls keep
shuyu locked as one one of them is the
girlfriend of the boy shuyu accidentally
killed she seems calm but plans to take
Revenge by mixing poison in shuu's food
but another girl eats it and dies on the
spot the remaining ones start doubting
each other and grab the guns they shoot
each other to death while the real
culprit is alive she blames herself for
this incident and jumps down from the
lighthouse after unlocking shuyu he is
still not fully recovered but drags
himself to find noro and kada they are
at The Shrine where noro dreams about
Kitano and says that Tano seemed lonely
being an adult is not as easy as the
youth think kaada advises her not to
think too much and wait for shuyu he is
already close to the shrine and keeps
thinking about his dad who was always
stressed about not getting a job shuu
didn't know how to deal with this
situation and then his dad suddenly died
his last message was go shuu you can do
it noro can sense shuyu is near and
wanders around to find him she gets
encountered by mitsuko who wants to kill
her but runs away on seeing Kitano
he liked what noro said about her dream
and gave her an umbrella meanwhile
sugiura eventually finds his Crush
kohiki but she gets scared and shoots
him sugiura confesses his love and tells
kohiki to stay safe kohiki regrets
acting too fast but sugura is already
dead now mitsuko reaches there and kills
kohiki she recalls her unfortunate
childhood that made her so insensitive
her mother was a prostitute and a man
tried to assault mitsuko but she had
learned to protect herself but she
finally meets her competition kirama she
shoots him several times but kirama is
wearing a bulletproof jacket he kills
mitsuko and continues looking for others
his next Target is mima's Gang they have
prepared their bombs and are working on
hacking the system after hundreds of
tries mimura finally succeeds and shuts
down the system the necklace can no
longer kill anyone the whole team is
panicking but katano stays calm and
orders to restart the system Mora loads
a truck with the bombs to complete their
plan but suddenly hears someone coming
it's kirama he starts shooting blindly
and the gunfire triggers the bombs
shuu's group reached there but
everything is covered in Flames however
kirama is still alive kada is done with
running away and faces kiriyama kada
succeeds in killing him but gets
severely injured only him shuyu and noro
are left they head to the seashore where
kada confesses that he was just using
them the whole time to win by himself
the story about his girlfriend was also
a joke saying this kada grabs the gun to
shoot them Kitano system gets an alert
that only kada is alive now the team
wants to search for him but Kitano tells
them to leave afterwards he waits for
kada the one who hacked the system is
actually kada who did this months ago to
avenge the death of his girlfriend shuyu
and noro are alive too Kitano shows them
a painting with Naro as the main
character as she has the purest heart if
Kitano could choose a winner it would
would be noro he takes out his gun and
tells noro to shoot him if she doesn't
want to die she can't bring herself to
do it but shuyu does later they realized
that Kitana was holding a water gun he
didn't intend to kill noro and wishes
his own daughter was respectful like her
too after Kitano dies the three
survivors ride a boat home but kada dies
due to his injuries his last words were
thank you just like his girlfriend
because he finally understood why she
said that she was grateful for finding
him and kada was grateful to find shuyu
and noro after reaching the city they
both have to stay underground as they
are declared murderers by the government
they may have to keep running all their
lives but at least they have each other
trust is giving someone the opportunity
to destroy you but we can't live alone
either everyone needs a little love care
and attention